hallo mein name ist luca und wir reden
heute wieder mit dem akinator
beziehungsweise kann er gar nicht reden
deswegen suchen wir davon wissen sie
natürlich wieder auf der akinator
website und ich sehe schon ich wurde
wieder gespielt deutsche kolonie wird
mir wurde erst mal gesagt das ukulele
jetzt auch schon sauer aufgespielt wurde
das heißt wir versuchen jetzt erstmal
kollegen zu finden meine figur wurde
durch youtube berühmt meine figur spielt
nicht den rang zwei mit skis kein mensch
sie hat kein tierisches aus
ich besteht eine figur aus holz ja
kennst du den nachnamen deiner figur
wir brauchen nachnamen foucault lilly
was könnte ein nachname für eine fackel
pläne seien
was mache ich nur einen finger schreibt
man nachnamen für die in die kommentare
die irgendwie angemessen klingen aber
ich erst mal ich kenne nicht den
nachnamen eingereicht von kollege ich
denke eine komödie alles klar
das bild ist auch übels schön eigentlich
muss ich sagen es gar nicht wo die dass
herr mach ich hatte das ja hier auf der
ukulele seite mal gepostet coli die hat
übrigens instagram dass mein account
ukulele mit 3i weil der normale ukulele
account leider schon vergeben ist da hab
ich dieses bild gepostet und das haben
die dann wahrscheinlich da eingereicht
gut gemacht freunde ja es ist kollegen
ukulele 125000 157 mal gespielt was ich
schaue jetzt gerade hier mal ganz kurz
wie jetzt dritte frage legt seine
figuren cottbuser silva hat deine figur
große brust
nein hat sie nicht nein sie ist kein
telefon nein sie packt nicht gerne nein
sie spielt nicht so man ein wird nichts
mit dem sport zu tun nein sie ist nicht
bei den nürnberger prozessen aber einen
vollbart
die a 7 mit controller ist die figur mit
kohl ich liebe freunde die ja und in
deine figur
seit juli ist um cornelia jorge was
dieses bild eingereicht wer hat dieses
bild von mir eingereicht
das ist nicht schön
ja es stimmt aber und ich wurde auch
schon 176 tausend mal gespielt alter wie
crazy ist dass ihr wurde gesagt das sei
viel auch einfach hier aus meinem
aufnahme zimmer da eingereicht wurde
deswegen versuchen jetzt einfach mal
meinen computer zu finden nein mein
computer hat kein handy ja zweite frage
kommt schon was von mir wollte es
einfach so die erste frage schon hat
irgendwas mit kontrabass tour führt ist
eine figur die flasche nein hat eine
figur bei einer casting show mitgemacht
nein ist nicht eine puppe hinein ist
eine figur auf einem berühmten gemälde
zu sehen nein trainiert deine figur
häufig schon guten bizeps und deine
figur mit konkreter jahr ist eine figur
groß wahrscheinlich ist eine figur
kantig ja wurde deine figur von craft
erfunden nein ist eine figur juni als
zehn jahre ja fast eine figur eine
flasche wein ist eine weko erst kürzlich
berühmt geworden ist eigentlich noch nie
berühmt geworden nein ist deine figur
größer als einen meter aneinander was
mit elektrizität zu tun hast deine figur
neben crafter ja kontrastieren wie crazy
tc von contrast er nur zum zocken da
kontrakte ich bin traurig ja es ist mein
pc und mein pc wurde auch schon 32 mal
gespielt haben wirklich leute nach
meinem pc gesucht warum mal schauen ob
ich mein handy finde wieder als zweite
frage lebt der nötigen kraft das zimmer
ja tut sie kommt eine figur seine
kollegen geschäft nein ist eine figur er
humorvoll
also wenn man sich dass siri video
anschaut was ich euch hier mal verlinkt
habe dann würde ich wirklich sagen wenn
handys humorvoll also krieg ich auch
versöhnliche nein meine figur es keine
flasche ja sie wohnt mit konkreter sie
ist kein tier sie passt
ich würde sagen nein meine figur ist
nicht groß ich kenne nicht den namen
einer figur siehst nicht aus holz sie
hat keine augen sie kommt nicht aus
berlin sie ist sehr klein von craft dass
staub
nein ist die karriere deiner figur immer
noch aktuell das handy eine karriere
übrigens meinten viele als ich diese
hülle mal gezeigt hatte mit dem smiley
drauf schleichwerbung du willst das man
dir das kauft erstens man kann diese
hülle nicht kaufen weil ich die nie
produzieren werde weil die quali einfach
scheiße war und das hab ich mir wirklich
selber design und so geguckt wie das
aussehen würde es ja zwar cool aus aber
ich denke ich werde kleine handy hüllen
davon machen oder wir sind ja derzeit am
neuen merchandise plan mit dem smiley
halt und da sind die sachen derzeit in
der produktion allerdings produzieren
wir in italien deswegen kostet das
wahrscheinlich ein ganz klein bisschen
mehr als andere merchandise aber es ist
auf jeden fall qualitativ hochwertige
haben wir wollten halt auch so sachen
machen wie den smiley teilweise wirklich
drauf sticken also nicht so larry mäßig
wie jeder das machst du drauf drucken
das natürlich auch weil das bei manchen
stoffen fahren das nicht geht aber wir
wollten beispielsweise in hude pullover
machen wo wir den smiley quasi drauf
sticken und wir wollten vielleicht auch
eine mütze machen wohl erstmal die hier
vorne drauf kommt was haltet ihr davon
wollt ihr das aber wir versuchen
weiterhin mein handy zu finden nein ich
das nicht aktuell sie hatten nichts mit
wäsche zu tun sie hat etwas mit
elektrizität sind und arbeitest du mit
deiner figur ja wahrscheinlich gehört
deine figur von crafter jetzt deine
figur neben crafter jahr ist eine figur
japanischen hat eine figur weniger
warum weiß hat er nicht schon dass das
handy ist es ist klein auch elektrizität
und gehört mir das kann nur mein handy
sein ist eine für mit einem fisch
befreundet wie mit fisch befreundet
gronau existiert eine figur ja seine
figur ja denn die würden betriebssystem
meego männlich ich weiß nicht lukas
handy handy von crafter
sogar ihr könnt alle nicht schreiben ja
es war mein handy und auch schon 67 mal
gespielt da suchen wirklich 67 leute
explizit nach meinem handy warum
an dieser stelle beende ich jetzt hier
dieses video es hat mir mal wieder den
rest gegeben mit diesem typen hier zu
reden denn ihr ideen wie ich eventuell
dieser akinator serie so ein bisschen
umfangreicher gestalten könnte also wenn
ihr denkt okay luca du sollst jetzt in
jeder als folge versuchen etwas zu
finden oder wenn die ideen konzepte hab
dann schreibt in die kommentare
jetzt hat immer nur die gänge hier
komplett gesucht haben dann würde ich
mich freuen wenn ihr das video mit einer
positiven bewertung bewährten werdet